olá é minha fala de entender sobre como
a gente pode mudar a nossa relação com
política usando tecnologia e aí pra
falar disso é preciso situar um pouco
todo mundo numa coisa fundamental da
nossa sociedade quase toda sociedade
moderna chamada democracia
representativa é um nome engraçado pra
uma coisa comum
o problema é que a gente resolve com
democracia representativa o problema é
que nós somos gente demais
a gente se via uma lei nossa decidir
como usar uma verba que nós temos que
projeta iniciar a gente decide uma coisa
em comum a gente não consegue ouvir todo
mundo a gente não consegue levar a
opinião de todo mundo em conta é muita
gente
então a solução que a gente inventou é
nóis todo mundo mas elegemos um pequeno
número de pessoas nossos representantes
e esses representantes sim eles discutem
voltam deliberam decidem muita coisa do
nosso coletivo a gente delega pra eles
a gente deixa escolhas interior isso é
muito bom isso funciona - gente mais
eficientes e conseguem resolver as
coisas
o problema é que pelo menos no brasil
a verdade é que a gente não confiar
nesse sistema a gente não confia nos
representantes que a gente elegeu e que
estão lá legislando por nós
se você conversar com qualquer pessoa
sobre política ela vai dizer você que
ela tem a impressão de que um político
eleito ele passa a agir muito mais em
benefício próprio ou em benefício de
outros grupos do que em benefício de nós
os cidadãos que precisam mais sair eu
não estou falando de corrupção tô
falando e agindo dentro da lei
só para dar um exemplo a câmara dos
deputados aí da foto é recentemente
aprovou a manutenção do financiamento
empresarial de campanhas e campanhas
políticas financiadas por empresas a
opinião pública estava veementemente
contra isso
os caras já provaram isso
e aí claro muita gente ficou indignada
eu por exemplo fiquei indignado essa é a
mesma indignação eu gosto de lembrar que
em 2013 fez acontecer alguma coisa em
2003 vocês lembrarem nós éramos milhões
e não era pelos vinte centavos
a gente estava indignado a gente foi pra
rua pra dizer que a gente estava
insatisfeito com que nossos
representantes fazia a gente não sabe
direito o que fazer quando foi para a
rua mas a gente foi lá e fez bastante
barulho e aí tem uma imagem e 2013 que
eu gosto muito e quando essa câmara dos
deputados foi ocupada pelos
manifestantes que chegaram lá o pessoal
não só fui lá e disse que estava
insatisfeito com que os representantes
do dem estavam fazendo mas subiu no teto
da câmara ocupou o teto e gritou em alto
e bom som que estava insatisfeito que
estava de olho estava vendo o que eles
representantes estavam fazendo e eu
gosto das imagens que eu acho que ela
tem uma coisa assim de certa na nossa
relação com nossos representantes e acho
que a gente tem que tá em cima da cama a
gente a gente tem que estar de olho
a gente está gritando pra eles que a
gente está vendo que o poder emana do
povo que a gente eu poder tem que servir
ao povo
mas aí se a gente voltar pro futuro a
eu posso perguntar pra vocês aí vocês
acham que a gente ainda está de olho em
vocês acham que a gente sabe o que foi
votado na câmara dos deputados nos
outros 15 dias
acho que alguém aqui sabe dizer como o
deputado que você elegeu votou nas
coisas importantes foram votadas nos
últimos 15 30 ou 60 dias
são coisas importantes é que decidem
muita coisa da nossa vida
de eleger os caras lá pra votar por nós
de repente a gente não sabe o que estão
fazendo lá
a gente não sabe o que estão fazendo
tá também é um pouco injusto querer que
a gente acompanha isso em detalhes são
dezenas de proposições por mês
muitas proposições do total são 513
deputados ativos por vez
é um monte de discurso em torno desse
monte de proposições que gera um monte
de votações manobra de madrugada é
complicado principalmente é complicado
porque a gente tem praticamente nenhuma
forma sistemática de acompanhar isso de
olhar pra isso pra essa atividade dos
nossos deputados aí um grupo de pessoas
do qual eu faço parte
nós somos departamento de sistemas e
computação da ufcg resolveu que essa
indignação tinha que vir alguma coisa a
gente tinha que fazer ao e aí bom sendo
departamento de sistemas de computação
que a gente sabe fazer muito bem são
sistemas
a gente fez uma ferramenta computacional
e fez duas na verdade que eu quero
mostrar para vocês
a primeira se chama quem representa o
quê que representa um site que convida o
visitante você a dizer como você teria
votado em uma série de proposições no
céu de votações que aconteceram
recentemente na câmara dos deputados
só para dar um exemplo de 2015 tem a
apec da terceirização a redução da
maioridade penal de 18 para 16 anos o
fim da reeleição a manutenção do
financiamento empresarial para campanhas
políticas
e aí você vê né são coisas para as quais
a maioria de nós ou tem alguma convicção
seria bom se tivesse alguma convicção
visitando o que ele representa você vai
lá e assinala quais são as suas
convicções suas opiniões sobre as
votações e diz como você teria votado ea
gente usa os dados abertos da câmara
para analisar
dos 513 deputados que estão lá quem te
representa quem votou mais parecido com
as suas convicções que voltou mais
diferentes suas convicções talvez seja
sua posição ea gente mostra então com
dados para cada deputado o que ele faz
em relação a você
mais ou menos 70 mil pessoas já
visitaram o que ele representa é isso de
um monte de feedback para a gente que
tem sido fascinante em feedback comum
por exemplo interessante mesmo é que é
muito freqüente que o deputado que
aparece no topo da lista o deputado que
mais representa não seja o deputado em
quem você votou acontece com muita gente
e aí eu acho isso causa imediatamente
uma discussão muito saudável quem é esse
cara que tá então no topo da lista será
que algum deputado que deveria conhecer
e eu não conheço nunca devia ter votado
nele não porque eu acho ele mais
carismático porque eu acho que ele fala
bem ou é bonito mas porque a partir dos
dados ou vendo que as ações desse cara
condizem com as minhas convicções
isso é importante a gente se desenvolver
precisa conseguir acompanhar os nossos
políticos
e aí tem duas coisas que eu acho muito
instigantes que essa discussão traz a
primeira é que quando a gente se
questiona será que eu não conheço então
o deputado que elegi ea gente vai atrás
e descobre que a não mas aqui ele votou
contra a minha convicção contra o
discurso dele na verdade porque ele tem
que responder ao partido à coligação a
bancada ao as alianças que ele tem e aí
a gente se questionando envolvido você
passa a praça fica mais fácil você se
coloca no lugar dele prestar o que é que
eu teria feito nesse lugar
talvez faça com que a gente entenda mas
não deixa de se envolva mais com a
realpolitik também que envolve sim
partidos e alianças e coligações mas a
segunda coisa que eu acho que é mais
instigante do que ele representa é coisa
aqui pra mim é mais mais bonita é que
ela muda um pouco a relação possível
entre nós e os representantes que nós
elegemos que ele representa em poder a
gente dá um poder pra gente novo de
conseguir questionar um deputado
facilmente dizer por que é que você fez
isso isso isso nessas três votações nas
quais com as quais eu estava contando
com você você um deputado em quem votei
um deputado do meu estado um deputado do
partido que eu simpatizo até o deputado
cuja história o respeito por que você
fez isso eu acho que é importante que a
gente tenha capacidade de
falar de igual para igual com os nossos
representantes e cobrá los e dizer para
eles que sim
nós estamos de olho no que estão fazendo
mas isso o que representa permita que a
gente veja alguns deputados
muita gente ainda tem dificuldade em
entender não um deputado específico mas
a câmara como um todo
eu por exemplo antes de começar esse
projeto eu ficava em casa jantar mas
quais são os grupos que existem dentro
da câmara quais são as forças que
existem mas são os maiores grupos
menores como é que os deputados com o
qual todo com um panorama da cama
segundo o projeto que a gente
desenvolveu ele se chama rosa cunha é
uma referência duas coisas ao seriado
house of cards que fala dos bastidores
da política americana ea um deputado em
particular protagonista do começo de
na câmara de deputados rosa ficou em a
gente pega de novo todos os dados
abertos da câmara de deputados e usam a
mágica lá da estatística chamada análise
correspondentes músicas pra criar um
panorama um mapa da atuação de todos os
deputados da câmara nesse mapa dos
deputados estão próximos uma pena a
gente cria tem essa cara aqui e aí dois
deputados estão cada nome desse um
deputado dos deputados tão próximo com
ele eles têm atuação semelhante dos
deputados tão distantes quanto a atuação
deles é oposta eles voltam sempre
diferentes nas proposições o que é
mágica já disse que faz a distribuição
os caras da forma que a gente mais
consegue distinguir os uns dos outros e
aí eu coloquei aqui o partido por
exemplo fica muito fácil se situar no
mapa que a gente tem o vermelho vivo o
pt é circundado aí pelos outros partidos
da base governista
essa nuvem maior da esquerda e no
extremo oposto em azul
você tem o psdb e demais deputados e
demais partidos de oposição ao governo a
abaixo você tem o a terceira força que
no momento a gente usa para descrever
política do brasil é a terceira maior
força o pmdb um partido o nome está
entre situação e oposição um pouco mais
próximo da situação geralmente tem um
quarto grupo pequenininha lá em cima dos
deputados de atuação extremamente
progressista os amarelos são o pessoal e
aí o que eu quero chamar atenção aqui é
que nós seres humanos nós somos muito
melhores e entender padrões
visualmente entender padrões gráficos do
que entender padrões em texto ou em
números
então de posse de um mapa de se com
algumas referências a gente consegue
situar muito facilmente em qual é a
atuação de um deputado em particular
quais são os dos maiores grupos que
existe na câmara dos deputados os
partidos que têm maior dispersão tem
deputados que atuam nas formas mais
diferentes mas coisas nos seus partidos
que atuam de qualquer forma e é só para
ilustrar a gente pode olhar por exemplo
quais são os deputados que têm a suas
campanhas financiadas normalmente por
empresas de munição e armas chamada
bancada da bala bancada armamentista lá
embaixo do mapa quase oposta à bancada
dos deputados humanista dos deputados
que levantar as bandeiras dos direitos
humanos na câmara dos deputados como
essas duas bancadas podem olhar várias
outras vários outros grupos quem votou a
favor de uma coisa que votou a favor de
outra quem apoia uma certa causa e e de
novo esse é o tema que eu quero chegar
podendo fazer isso você tem um espécie
de poder novo na sua relação com seus
representantes na sua relação com a
política assim como quem representa o
objetivo aqui em poderá o cidadão
e aí novamente a gente tem encontrado
várias pessoas que têm entendido mais
política por causa desse mapa gente tem
visto os jornalistas que têm comentado a
câmera usando esses mapas
eu gosto de achar que agora a gente tem
também representantes sabendo que nós
estamos de olho neles
através desses mapas dessas ferramentas
no fundo elas fazem é que elas estão
tornando possível processar muitos dados
é e de uma forma que não só é mais
eficiente que a gente consegue entender
mais rapidamente que está acontecendo
mas é mais envolvente né
ela traz a gente pra se preocupar para
conseguir opinar na política de uma
forma mais atrativa e eu acho que isso é
muito importante eu acho que a gente tem
que se envolver no controle social já
tem que se envolver na política não só
durante as eleições mas entre as
eleições têm que ser uma atividade que
atrai que traz a gente que instiga a
gente já tentou fazer isso com duas
ferramentas que já descobriu foi que
existe um potencial enorme para muito
mais
é mais do que nunca hoje
a gente tem dados a gente tem muito dado
aberto
mais do que nunca hoje a gente tem
tecnologia dos nossos bolsos celulares
laptop em casa
então o que eu proponho gente é que a
gente acorde pra isso e passa a fazer
mais ferramentas como essas para
melhorar os nossos votos ea nossa
política
obrigado